devops a combination of development and
operations is a software development
approach that emphasizes collaboration
Automation and continuous integration
and delivery devops has gained immense
popularity in recent years due to its
ability to enhance software development
processes streamline operations and
improve overall efficiency so if you're
interested in learning devops from
scratch this video will guide you
through a comprehensive roadmap
providing you with a clear path to
mastering the principles and practices
of devops but before that if you want to
learn about devops and its concept in
depth then simply learns Caltech
postgraduate program in devops will be
the right choice for you this devops
course is designed in collaboration with
caltex ctme for a professional
development option that will Square your
skills with industry standards in this
course you will learn how to formalize
and document development process and
create a self documenting system devop
certification course will also cover
Advanced tools like puppet Souls tag and
ansible that helps self-governance and
automated management at scale so why
wait check out the course link mentioned
in the description now let's dive into
the video but let's start with
understanding the different software
development methodologies present out
there will software development models
also known as software development
methodologies or processes are
systematic approaches used to plan
design develop and deliver software
applications there are several different
types of software development models
each with its own set of principles
practices and characteristics so first
among them is waterfall model the
waterfall model is a sequential software
development approach that follows a
linear progression through various
phases including requirements Gathering
design implementation testing deployment
and maintenance each phase is complete
dated before moving on to the next and
it relies heavily on upfront planning
and documentation it is often used in
projects with well-defined requirements
and stable environments second is agile
model now Asian methodologies such as
scrum and kanbin emerged as a response
to the limitations of the waterfall
method agile focuses on iterative and
incremental development with frequent
feedback and collaboration between
cross-functional teams the project is
divided into smaller time box iterations
and Sprints where features are developed
tested and delivered in a rapid and
flexible manner agile methodologies
prioritize adaptability customer
satisfaction and continuous Improvement
and third is devops now devops is not a
software development model per se but
rather a cultural and operational
philosophy that emphasizes collaboration
and integration between software
development and it operations teams it
aims to automate and streamline the
entire software delivery pipeline from
development and testing to deployment
and monitoring devops encourages closer
collaboration shared responsibilities
and the use of automation tools to
achieve faster and more Reliable
Software releases it promotes a
continuous delivery approach allowing
frequent and smaller updates to be
deployed in short devops is a philosophy
and set of practices that transcends
traditional software development models
it emphasizes collaboration automation
continuous delivery and a holistic view
of software development by an operations
by combining development and operations
into a unified approach devops strives
to achieve faster more reliable and
customer-centric software delivery now
that we have understood why devops is
different from other software
development models and why is it so
important to learn now let's see how you
can learn devops from scratch so the
first step is understand the Core
Concepts well to embark on your devops
journey it is crucial to grasp The Core
Concepts devops involves cultural
process and Technical aspects start by
understanding the key principles such as
continuous Integra duration continuous
delivery infrastructure as code and
automation continuous integration
involves integrating code changes
frequently into a shared repository and
running automated tests to catch issues
early continuous delivery focuses on
automating the deployment process
ensuring that software is always in a
releasable state infrastructure as code
emphasizes managing infrastructure
resources through code enabling
scalability consistency and
reproductibility automation plays a
pivotal role in reducing manual effort
and increasing efficiency throughout the
software development cycle second is
learn Version Control System well
version control system is a fundamental
aspect of devops get a widely used
Version Control System allows you to
track changes in your code base
collaborate with team members and manage
different versions of your code so begin
by learning the basic of git commands
such as initializing a repository
creating branches committing changes and
merging branches gain hands-on
experience by creating repositories
collaborating with others using git and
understanding branching strategies that
facilitate parallel development and
merging code changes third is Master
configuration management now
configuration management is essential
for efficient management and deployment
of software configurations across
various environments explore popular
configuration management tools like
ansible Chef or puppet these tools
enable you to define the desired state
of your infrastructure and automate
configuration management task learn how
to write infrastructure code known as
playbooks or recipes which specify the
desired configuration of servers and
services automating configuration
management ensures consistency reduces
manual errors and simplifies
infrastructure management at scale then
dive into continuous integration and
continuous delivery now continuous
integration and continuous delivery are
integral to devops practices enabling
teams to deliver software rapidly and
reliably CI involves regularly
integrating code changes into a shared
repository and running automated test to
identify issues early explore popular CI
CD tools like Jenkins Travis Ci or
gitlab CI CD setup cicd pipelines which
automate the build test and deployment
processes learn how to configure these
pipelines to compile and test code run
unit test execute integration test and
deploy applications to various
environments gain hands-on experience in
automating the release process and
delivering software frequently with
confidence next is Embrace
infrastructure as code infrastructure as
code is a vital component of modern
devops practices it involves managing
infrastructure resources through code
enabling you to provision and configure
infrastructure programmatically learn
tools like terraform or AWS cloud
formation to Define infrastructure
resources such as servers networking and
storage understand the declarative
nature of infrastructure code and how it
allows for reproductibility and
scalability gain knowledge of cloud
platforms like AWS Azure or Google cloud
and explore their respective devops
tooling to automate infrastructure
provisioning scaling and monitoring next
explore containerization and
orchestration now containerization
Technologies like Docker have
revolutionized software development by
providing lightweight isolated
environments for applications Begin by
understanding containers their benefits
and how they differ from traditional
virtual machines learn how to create and
manage Docker containers package your
applications into containers and ensure
consistency across different
environments die given to container
orchestration platforms like kubernetes
which allows you to automate the
deployment scaling and management of
containers understand Concepts like pods
deployments services and Ingress and
gain practical experience by deploying
applications using containerization and
orchestration tools next adopt
monitoring and logging monitoring and
logging play a crucial role in ensuring
application stability and performance
learn about monitoring tools like
Prometheus grafana or nagios which
enables you to collect and visualize
metrics and gain insights into the
health of your systems exclude logging
Frameworks like the elk stack like
elasticsearch log stash kibana which
provides a centralized platform for
collecting analyzing and visualizing
logs understand how to set up monitoring
and blogging systems configure alerting
and troubleshoot issues in real time and
gain insights into the performance
availability T and reliability of your
applications next emphasize security and
compliance security is an essential
aspect of devops practices in corporate
security principles and best practices
India devops workflow learn about secure
coding practices vulnerability scanning
tools and penetration testing
methodologies understand compliance
standards and Frameworks like PCI DSS
HIPAA and gdpr and ensure that your
systems are there to these regulations
explore security focused tools and
techniques to protect your
infrastructure applications and data
Implement secure authentication
authorization and encryption mechanisms
to ensure the integrity and
confidentiality of your systems Nexus
continuous learning and Improvement well
devops is a continuously evolving field
with new tools and Technologies emerging
regularly stay updated with the latest
industry Trends by following blogs
forums and and conferences engage with
the devops community participate in
discussions and contribute to open
source projects continuous learning and
Improvement are key to mastering devops
take a projects experiment with
different tools and techniques and
continually refine your skills
participate in hackathons attend
workshops and pursue relevant
certifications to enhance your knowledge
and stay competitive so now that you
have explored how you can learn devops
from scratch here's a success story of
one of our Learners to help you
understand the impact and importance of
devops and to boost your confidence for
upskilling so do watch it I started my
ID Journey with Accenture three years
ago I joined there as a cloud architect
there I worked with AWS and Azure
Technologies I was anyway looking for
higher paying job and devops seem the
right career choice so I decided to go
with the postgraduate programming devops
in collaboration with Caltech ctme
course was divided into modules
and we had assignments I was really
impressed by how many job interviews I
landed after I added the certification
to my portfolio and now I am earning 40
more than my previous job didn't only
boost my career but also my confidence
well embarking on the devops journey
requires dedication continuous learning
and hands-on experience with various
tools and Technologies by following this
comprehensive roadmap you can develop a
solid foundation in devops principles
and practices well if you like this
video and found it interesting and
informative then please do give it a
thumbs up and share it with your friends
also if you have any questions then
please feel free to ask away in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible till then
keep learning and thank you staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in Cutting
Edge domains including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign